what do we do when we can't go out to
watch good movies and then if you're a
geek you also rank them hey folks so
this is something I've been thinking
about doing for a while I am going to
rank all the films directed by the
legendary Hayao Miyazaki now it is only
going to be the films directed by him
it's not gonna be every film released by
Studio Ghibli cuz despite the fact that
people think they're synonymous there
were other directors there at that
studio um and in addition I'm not doing
any of the shorts
so that means that I have 11 films to
rank starting from 1979 with Castle
cogliostro going all the way up to the
wind rises so let's start at the bottom
and we work our way up and since I
already mentioned it let's start with
the castle of Cagliostro which I think I
mispronounced when I said it earlier
anyways I actually debated whether or
not to even put this one on the list
I've noticed a lot of lists of
Miyazaki's films either ignore this one
are given a very passing mention because
the thing is the entire property of
Lupin the third which this is related to
was a pre-existing property pre-existing
manga there were already animated films
so it this is the least miyazaki
Miyazaki film ever made and it's also
the first film he ever directed but at
the same time you can see a lot of the
of the signatures that would very much
become to be prominent in his later
works a lot of the pacing of some of the
scenes the way shots linger on things
that aren't the main characters the
setting of some of the castles itself
some of them the mechanisms going on it
there's even like a weird funky flying
device so there's
notes of his Seng sure stuff than the
music while not being from his standard
collaborator that he used for most of
his movies is still reminiscent of what
you used to hearing in Miyazaki film but
at the same time it still comes in at
the bottom because these are not
characters you would expect Miyazaki to
be dealing with he did try and mold them
to his own sense of how a hero should be
from what I could tell I don't know a
ton about Lupin the third who is a bit
of a international thief he's way more
lecherous and a bit of a skis normally
and he's a bit more hero here he's not
totally shed the skis thing but it's not
nearly as prominent as I guess it was in
other instances so you can feel Miyazaki
trying to mold it into his own thing but
he's still kind of restrained by what
the property is and so we'll move on
from here and also I should note that
actually none of these films and
especially none of the ten that most
people consider to be proper Miyazaki
films none of these are backed these are
all good movies every single one of them
is worth watching if you haven't so
honestly this entire ranking is just a
matter of taste so let's move up to
number 10 in the number 10 spot we have
castle in the sky what is about castles
it didn't bring out his best work castle
on the sky has some absolutely beautiful
moments and visuals and vibe but it's
also got sort of the most nebulous story
it's just we want to get to this
floating castle and we're here now okay
and his stories can't be meandering but
this feels much more like a quest
narrative but it kind of lacks the
forward thrust you'd want out of a quest
narrative it's also his only film aside
from castle of Cagliostro that has a
definitive clear-cut villain like no
qualms this isn't like just an
antagonist like flat-out villain and
that's it's kind of weird
enemy izaki them they have somebody that
clear-cut as the bad guy this is a bad
person and that that doesn't help either
it's still well put together and there's
definitely some visuals especially sort
of some some of these ancient robots
that you see they're gorgeous in the way
they move is amazing but if that vibe is
not pervasive enough across the film for
it to get any higher than the 10 spot
number 9 it's gonna be Porco Rosso this
one this is an odd one it does play into
one of Miyazaki's great loves that of
flying and flying contraptions and the
entire thing being based around
basically dogfights and air pirates so
it is in his wheelhouse in some ways but
it it's an it's got an odd feel to it I
think between the somewhat more
traditional masculine hero which is a
which feels in many ways out of place in
a Miyazaki film and just sort of the
meandering of events but again a little
bit like castle in the sky it feels like
it should have a firmer narrative
because like you've got basically a
flying ace who is a you know a great
pilot a great dog fighter it feels like
he should have a clearer story as
opposed to sort of doing the more of me
and I will just wander from here to here
and here's some of these characters and
bring this in an age just sort of wrap
it up another sort of lays a fair way
which normally works for Miyazaki but it
feels a little bit out of place with
this kind of story so number eight is
going to be Nausicaa of the valley of
the wind so this is what many people
consider to be the first proper Miyazaki
film because this was the first one that
was entirely his idea his thing as
opposed to castle of Cagliostro which
was his first feature film but not
really his characters his franchise his
notions so this is
really steeped in what you expect out of
a Miyazaki film strong female
protagonist in your main lead character
amazing world crazy creatures weird
flying contraptions a strong
environmental message it's all year and
there's there's cute creatures there's
there's huge intimidating ones but even
those ones have a have kind of a
serenity to them and it's it's big and
it's epic and this has one of the larger
stories that you would get from Miyazaki
as time would go on he would kind of
focus in on an even with story set in
big fantasy where else would narrow the
focus in whereas this is a bit more of
the these are kingdoms clashing you know
these are world shaping events were
looking at which you don't often get
from Miyazaki I don't think that
necessarily inherently drags it down but
it is a little bit bloated it runs a
little bit longer than it probably needs
to and you do sort of well you have all
of his signatures in it they're not
quite refined yet they're not quite
polished it's a little rough around the
edges just and actually not even in and
of itself but just in terms of how
cleanly he's able to do things down the
road still a good movie though so at
number seven we have the wind rises at
present the last feature film created by
Hayao Miyazaki and I know a lot of
people really sort of cheered for this
to win an Oscar the year that it came
out but I think that was wanting to give
him a one more major award as he was
going out because this wow this is a
visually gorgeous film and the scope is
is very sweet and very intimate because
it is I was almost gonna say a real-life
story it's not really but it's about an
actual historical Japanese figure who
invented a very influential airplane
design and it does a really good
of shifting focusing on his life his
connections his relationships but also
this work in the the passion he has as
he's pursuing you know trying to refine
this airplane the thing is some of the
more standard Miyazaki flourishes like
some of the more exotic and whimsical
flying machine designs get crowbarred in
through a dream sequence and it really
does feel like he he couldn't bring
himself to not have that that was the
only way he could think to bring it it
doesn't feel like something organic to
the story it feels like something that
Miyazaki usually does and it's kind of
crowbar it in there it doesn't derail
the whole thing but it the it didn't fit
the vibe of the film up to that point
and largely it's that that kind of
brings it down and yet I say that at the
same time it's not like if it you remove
the whimsical elements it suddenly would
have been a better film because it is
way more grounded I actually find it a
little bit dull compared some of his
others but as with all these still worth
saying number six
Ponyo what we mean that in the best way
Miyazaki's take on the Little Mermaid
results in this little shape-shifting
fish blob that turns into a girl who
loves ham and the the world or at least
this town gets flooded but it's saved by
this massive water goddess and you've
got pond yos father who's kinda like a
human but he's like a wizard but he like
lives in the ocean and doesn't think
very well of people at all and you've
got this bonding of Ponyo and this young
boy oh it's a weird weird movie but it's
got such a great vibe and I think that's
part of what makes it weird yet
wonderful because you you are watching
this town get
threatened by like massive tsunami sized
waves but there's still this this loose
fantasy like oh isn't this Pleasant vibe
even as like the town gets flooded it's
very strange but it if you can let it
wrap you up in the vibe that it's is
bringing you to its it's a unique
experience this film number 5 Kiki's
Delivery Service this was just nice it's
just a nice pleasant story about a young
witch finding her place in the world and
her place is delivering packages it's
it's just a nice simple sweet kid story
I mean nearly everything that Miyazaki
has ever made is certainly kid-friendly
I do feel that this one more than any of
the others is specifically a kids story
the just the level of simplicity of it
and the matter-of-fact nature of it and
though and the way that it's it's kind
of like a growing up story but it's it's
so gentle it's not because if you ever
grow up story aimed at an older audience
you're generally going to get something
where someone has harsher life lessons
than go on here and it just is a soft
gentle hug of a film it's just really
sweet okay number four and here's the
placement that where everyone's gonna
yell at me number four is spirited away
and I know I know like spirit of aways
everyone else is number one now spirited
away is a great film absolutely no
question nearly all of these are for me
honestly it's the lead character I find
her to be one of Miyazaki's less
engaging protagonists she's not totally
unengaging she still were
but she she's unengaging in the way
Alice from Alice in Wonderland is
unengaging the world that she is now
inhabiting and is wandering through in
his existing it is so bursting seams
with imagination and magic and whimsy
and she's just a girl
and it's not even necessarily fall to
the character that's just kind of the
nature of the beast when you do a story
like this but for me that does make her
just less engaging and I find myself
always really wrapped up in everything
that isn't her she's functional she
doesn't she doesn't derail the film in
any way but I don't find myself rooting
for her as a character I just want to
spend more time in this world and Wow is
it an amazing world but that's the
reason it's not higher and that's me
saying like something that it's not
great about it but that's because I have
to justify wise not number one because I
feel like it's everyone else is number
one but so much inventiveness in this
movie and it's all just shown so
matter-of-factly which is something that
Miyazaki does that I loved including in
the next one number three Howl's Moving
Castle I like that he really rides the
line between magic being an everyday
thing and also feeling special because
when you get something like say Kiki's
Delivery Service yes some people are
impressed by the fact that she's a witch
no one's surprised by the fact that
she's a witch and she can do what she
can do so there isn't I think that's one
of the reasons Kiki is a little bit
lower for me it doesn't quite have the
same sense of wonder at the magical
elements they're just kind of there and
they're normal from there what I like
about Howl's Moving Castle is this is a
world in which magic is normal but not
everybody can do it and those who can't
do it
like are in a level of aw or fear of it
while it's normal to the world it's not
normal to everyone who lives in it and I
think that helps balance things and
gives a higher degree of that sense of
wonder to it that I really really enjoy
and I like Sophie a lot as a character
and I find howell kind of fascinating
for the sort of coward hero in quotes
that he is and Calcifer is great there's
a curse for you mail you bacon burn and
I enjoy the dynamic of the household in
Howl's Moving Castle when when so he
comes in and just basically takes the
place over
this young girl cursed into the body of
an old woman it goes in some odd places
towards in its third act and the wrap up
is a little hastily thrown together and
overly neat but I those are the reasons
why it's not higher but this uh-huh
this is a dang good one now number two
is my nostalgic favorite because my
number two pick was the first Miyazaki
film I ever saw and I even got to see it
in the theater then that one is Princess
Mononoke
I like the scale and the scope of this
this is the this is about as close as I
think Miyazaki has ever come to making a
properly adult film because there is
that sense of wonder and whimsy but also
of this world is dangerous and it is
being damaged and fighting back and
fighting back violently so having all
that brought together in a stunning
villain what is personally my favorite
soundtrack that any of the Miyazaki move
have and this amazing that oh the spirit
of the forest is one of the most
gorgeous things when it is when it's in
its translucent form and sort of moving
against the skyline it is stunning to me
I love the complexity of the villains in
this and of course yeah it's got giant
wolves and I love well I can't wait to
show this movie to my kid she's not
quite old enough to watch it yeah I
don't think but soon she'll she'll be
there soon I can't wait for her to see
this and I would totally understand it
for other people this is an ass high but
like I said this is the first Miyazaki
film I ever saw it has to be right up
there but it doesn't take my number one
spot my number one Miyazaki film for me
is my neighbor totoro to me that film is
the perfect distillation of everything
Miyazaki does well it is sweet and just
a little bit adventurous it is whimsical
and magical and yet also grounded and
these girls feel so real to me and even
more so now that I'm a parent I saw for
the first time before I had a kid and I
still got like wow those who really feel
like real kids and even more so now
that's astounding to me and it it
strikes that balance just right because
you have the girls who they're
experiencing these wonderful amazing
things and they get to bring that ahh to
it because this is amazing magical to
them yet they're also young enough to
just accept that it is the case they'll
they'll look at something like the
Catbus slack-jawed but they'll also roll
with it and it's really wonderful it is
the most finely balanced mix of familial
relations connect
into you know the earth and the place
where you live how we connect to each
other the importance of relationships
the importance of family and the wonder
of the world large-scale and small this
is a gorgeous film I think it is the
perfect example of everything that
Miyazaki is so good at and I personally
think it's his best film what do you
think how would you rank Miyazaki's
films however you would do it drop
something on down to comments let's talk
about it and until next time this
council is adjourned hey thanks so much
for watching there's all the usual
options that you can do light subscribe
if the Bell share this video all of
which help me out and help the channel
grow if you are the generous I don't
want to help more directly out of a
patreon to be a link at the end of this
video and also down in the description
you can get your name in the credits as
you are currently seeing for all these
people who helped make this channel what
it is today but you also don't have to
do any of that because at the end of the
day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings
stay safe out there
[Music]